ça n'aura échappé à personne l'idée fixe
de donald trump pendant ces quatre
années de mandat
et c'était la chine le milliardaire a
engagé un véritable bras de fer avec l'
empire du milieu bras de fer économique
d'abord avec la guerre douanières que se
livrent les deux pays depuis le début de
l'année 2018 des sanctions contre le
géant chinois des télécommunications
huawei ou la tentative de bannissement
de l'application tik tok bras de fer
diplomatique ensuite à peine élu donald
trump s'est entretenu avec tsai ming wen
la présidente taïwanaise ce qui a été
perçu comme une provocation par pékin il
a soutenu les manifestants hong kong et
s'est rapproché de l'inde dont les
relations avec la chine se sont
détériorées ces dernières années et
bradfer militaire enfin avec comme
démonstration de force le déploiement de
nombreux bâtiments de guerre américains
en mer de chine
et vous pouvez ajouter à tout ceci les
références répétées du milliardaire au
virus et chinois pour qualifier le
sascoc de cela dit l'amérique a first de
donald trump a aussi concerné le vieux
continent
l'administration américaine a annoncé
pour plusieurs milliards de dollars de
tarifs douaniers sur un ensemble de
produits européens en 2019 ainsi qu'en
juin et décembre dernier certaines
sanctions même visé directement la
france suite au projet de bercy de taxer
les gaffes à l'amérique de trump ça
aussi était celle de l'unilatéralisme
avec le retrait de nombreux traités
internationaux accords de paris sur le
climat accord de partenariat
transpacifique traité sur les forces
nucléaires à portée intermédiaire traité
ciel ouvert donald trump a également
retiré son pays de l'unesco a stoppé le
renouvellement du traité new start a
lancé une procédure pour quitter l'om s
et à dénoncer l'accord de vienne sur le
nucléaire iranien
ce retrait a d'ailleurs été suivie d'un
retour des sanctions américaines contre
téhéran
l'assassinât du très populaire général
iranien qasem soleimani le 3 janvier
2020 à bagdad ainsi que les récentes
sanctions contre les chefs de la
rébellion houti au yémen ont également
contribué à la dégradation des relations
entre l'iran et les états unis
côté militaire si trump peut se targuer
d'être le premier président à ne pas
avoir engagé de nous
conflit depuis reagan les etats unis
sont restés très actif avec une
augmentation de leur budget passé de 611
milliards de dollars en 2016 à 738
milliards en 2020 et la poursuite de
frappes ciblées comme à bagdad mais
aussi en syrie en libye ou en somalie
d'un autre côté trump est resté fidèle à
ses engagements de campagne en
accélérant le désengagement des troupes
américaines en irak ou en afghanistan ou
en somalie là encore les états membres
de l'otan se sont par ailleurs vu prier
d'assumer leur part de responsabilité de
la sécurité collective et de respecter
leurs engagements budgétaires
on peut enfin citer les dossiers
israéliens et nord-coréen
donald trump a été impuissante alliés
pour israël avec pour preuve le très
symbolique déménagement de l'ambassade
américaine à jérusalem est les accords
de normalisation signés avec bahreïn et
les émirats arabes unis citent quant aux
relations avec pyongyang
après un démarrage difficile une
rencontre historique a eu lieu entre kim
jong-un et donald trump en 2018
les deux dirigeants seraient même tombés
amoureux si l'on en croit le
milliardaire américain dans le plus pur
style qu'on lui connaît
quelles que soient les orientations
choisies par joe biden s'est malgré tout
avec l'héritage des années tron que le
nouvel hôte de la maison blanche devra
composer sa politique étrangère est une
chose est sûre le style sera
radicalement différent